Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Emre Göchtas.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Bevor wir anfangen, lassen Sie mich bitte Ihren persönlichen Daten notieren.
Danach besprechen wir Ihre Beschwerde.
Okay?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Jutta Schneider.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen Buchstabieren?
Ja, Jutta, J, U, T, T, A.
Und Schneider, S, C, H, N, E, I, D, E, R.
Okay.
Frau Schneider.
Wie alt sind Sie?
53 Jahre.
Und verraten Sie mir bitte Ihr Geburtsdatum?
Ja, 25. Mai 1968.
1968.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Schneider?
1,66 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
67 kg.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, 3 Kinder.
Ja, super.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, die sind gesund.
Die sind 30 Jahre, 27 und 24.
Die sind gesund.
Die leben aber nicht mehr zu hatten bei uns.
Ja, klar.
Und was sind Sie von Beruf, Frau Schneider?
Ich bin Verwaltungsangestellter.
Also, Frau Schneider, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ja, ich habe so seit 2 Tagen einen Schmerzen im Bauch.
Das nimmt jetzt zu, wird schlimmer.
Und ja, das muss jetzt untersucht werden.
Also, die Schmerzen sind zu stark geworden.
Okay, könnten Sie mir sagen, wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Ja, die sind so unter den Rippen, auf der rechten Seite, mehr unter den Rippen.
Und ziehen so ein bisschen in die Mitte, aber mehr rechts unter den Rippen.
Also, die Schmerzen strahlen in die Mitte aus?
Sie sind auch in der Mitte.
Manchmal habe ich den Eindruck, strahlt der Schmerz auch in die Schulter aus.
Okay.
Wie sind die Schmerzen?
Könnten Sie mir genau beschreiben, sind sie eher dumpf oder stechend oder krampartig, polykartig?
Das ist wie so ein Druckschmerz.
Und eher so ein bisschen dumpf, aber ein ziemlicher Druckschmerz.
Also, keine Kolik, aber ein Druckschmerz.
Ich verstehe.
Wie ist stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10?
0 ist keine Schmerzen, 10 ist strahliche Schmerzen.
Jetzt so in den letzten zwei Stunden, würde ich sagen, 7 bis 8.
Gestern waren sie vielleicht bei 5, 5 bis 6, aber jetzt zuletzt 7 bis 8.
Okay.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Also, ich habe eine Wärmflasche gestern Abend auf den Bauch gelegt.
Und das wird dann schlimmer.
Das war nicht gut. Die Wärmflasche war nicht gut. Die habe ich dann sofort wieder weggelegt.
Okay.
Und sind die Schmerzen nahrungsabhängig oder lagerabhängig?
Also, ich habe seit gestern nichts mehr gegessen, weil mir ist etwas übel.
Ich habe keinen Appetit. Da habe ich nur mal ein bisschen was getrunken,
aber gegessen habe ich nichts.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, sie, Ihnen ist übel und haben Sie erbrochen?
Nee, aber es ist so kurz davor.
Okay.
Und wieder zurück, Ihre Schmerzen.
Also, Sie haben seit zwei Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Haben Sie, haben Sie bemerkt, ob irgendwelche Auslöser gibt?
Ja, ja, wie ist, wie ist die Schmerzen eingefangen?
Auslöser, liebe, sind am Abend begonnen und ich war nachmittags,
war ich auf einem Geburtstag und da habe ich ziemlich viel Sahnekuchen gegessen.
Das kann sein, dass es danach irgendwie schlimmer wurde.
Vor drei Wochen hatte ich schon mal so etwas Ähnliches, aber überhaupt nicht so stark.
Okay.
Und also Sie haben schon mal solche Schmerzen gehabt, aber nicht so stark.
Nicht so stark. Und das hat auch nur einige Stunden gedauert.
Das war so vor drei Wochen.
Vorher haben Sie noch schon mal gehabt, oder das zweite Mal?
Nee, sonst noch nie.
Okay.
Und also Sie haben Sahnekuchen gegessen.
Kann diese Lebensmittelverdorbenes sein oder wissen Sie?
Nein, ich glaube nicht, dass das verdorben war.
Wenn man das verdorbenes esse, dann habe ich gleich Erbrechen oder Durchfall.
Okay.
Sie haben keine Probleme beim Stuhlgang.
Nee.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen also, fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Wie fühle ich mich?
Fühlen Sie sich fieblich?
Ja, ich hatte gestern und heute Morgen so etwas Schüttelfrost.
Ich habe nicht mal Temperatur gemessen und da hatte ich 38,5.
38,5.
Okay.
Und haben Sie dagegen, es war das Eingenommen?
Nein.
Legen Schmerzen, vielleicht?
Nee.
Ich nehme ganz selten Schmerzstabletten.
Und ich habe gehört, man sollte, wenn man so Bauchschmerzen hat,
auch möglichst keine Schmerzstabletten nehmen,
dann bestens sich untersuchen lassen.
Ja, ja.
Sie haben sehr gut gemacht, bei uns gekommen zu haben.
Ja, okay.
Okay.
Also, möchten Sie noch etwas ergänzen zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden?
Nee.
Okay.
Dann möchte ich ein paar Fragen über Ihre Vorgeschichte,
ein paar Fragestellen.
Wie haben Sie an chronische Erkrankungen wie Zuckerkrankheit,
Produkthochdruck oder?
Nee.
Also, ich habe eine leichte Schildrüse unter Funktion.
Und dann dafür nehme ich eine Tablette ein.
Was für Tablette nehmen Sie?
Die heißt Elbtyroxin 50.
Wie viel Mal?
Morgens, eine halbe Stunde vor dem Frühstück.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen noch eine Erkrankung bekannt?
Ja, ich habe so im Frühjahr, wenn die Bäume blühen,
dann habe ich manchmal so etwas freuchnupfen und Asthma.
Und dann nehme ich dann etwas Asthmaspray.
Aber nur im Frühjahr.
Das dauert so vier bis sechs Wochen,
und dann brauche ich das nicht mehr nehmen.
Okay.
Was für Spray benutzen Sie bei der?
Galbutamol.
Wissen Sie, wie geht es Ihnen?
Nein.
Ich habe das jetzt auch nicht mitgebracht.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich das eben dann nehme.
Aber im Augenblick brauche ich das nicht.
Es ist noch nicht so weit.
Okay.
Seit wann Sie Schilddruhsen unterfunktionen haben?
Das ist schon lange.
Das habe ich bestimmt schon 25 Jahre.
Ist Ihnen schon mal operiert worden?
Ich bin als Kind operiert worden an den Mandeln.
Mandeln und am Blendern als Kind.
Mandelentfernung und Midamentfernung.
Ja.
Okay.
Uns über Ihre Familie.
Gibt es irgendwelche wesentliche Erkrankungen
oder Vorerkrankungen?
Meine Eltern, die leben beide.
Mein Vater ist 84 Jahre alt.
Er hat soweit ich weiß hohen Blutdruck.
Er nimmt dafür Tabletten ein.
Aber ich weiß nicht, welche.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich meine Mutter.
Meine Mutter hat etwas Alterszucker.
Und hatte früher auch Gallensteine.
Ist daran auch operiert worden.
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Die ist zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Die ist im letzten Jahr an der Gallenglaser operiert worden.
Die hatte auch Gallensteine.
Also Frau Schneider.
Wie oft gehen Sie?
Ja, einmal im Jahr.
Alle 1,5 Jahre.
Okay.
Wann war die letzte Kontrolle?
Vor 3 Monaten.
Bekomme Sie noch Ihre Monatsbildung?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon im nächsten Jahr?
Oder auch nicht?
Der Frauenarzt sagt, ich bin so am Übergang.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Nein.
Ich kann gut schlafen.
Sie können gut durchschlafen, einschlafen.
Ich muss in der Nacht einmal auf Toilette Wasser lassen.
Aber danach kann ich wieder gut einschlafen.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ich habe noch nicht mehr.
Ich kann alles vertragen.
Bis vor 2 Tagen.
Außer mächtliches Wasser lassen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasser lassen?
Nein.
Ich kann das Wasser gut halten.
Ich habe noch nicht mehr.
Ist es etwas, was Sie nicht oder mental belastet?
Nein.
Eigentlich ist es sonst alles gut.
Ich habe meinen Freundeskreis,
meine Kontakte.
Das freut mich.
ältroxin nehmen sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein oder bei sie
benutzen bei Bedarf halb- und halb- und halb- und benutzten sie
für die Schildrüse nehme ich ältroxin ja habe ich notiert
und bei Bedarf aber sonst nehme ich nicht
Also jetzt noch einen Anamnese rauchen sie
Ja, ne Leider, ja, ich rauche so 50er Retten am Tag
Seit wann?
Seit circa 20 Jahren
20 Jahre
Okay, und trinken sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nicht jeden Tag, am Wochenende vielleicht mal ein bis zwei Glas Wein
Seit wann?
Hoch das mache ich ja eigentlich schon
immer
seitdem ich erwachsen bin
Nehmen sie Drohren, Herr Frauschneider?
Nein, habe ich auch noch nie genommen
Das ist gut
Und ist bei ihnen Allergie bekannt?
Ne, nur diese bei den
Beuschnupfen, ja
Beuschnupfensachen vielleicht, aber sonst habe ich keine Allergie mehr
Okay, Frau Schneider, meineseits habe ich die wichtigsten Fragen gestellt
Möchten Sie dazu noch etwas ergänzen oder haben Sie Fragen?
Ja, was denken Sie, was das sein kann?
Also Frau Schneider, ich verstehe Sie, ich verstehe ganz genau,
dass Sie die Ursache Ihre Beschwerden möglichst schnell wissen möchten
Aber gerade kann ich nicht genau sagen, was Sie haben
Erstmal, ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen
Danach, ich brauche auch eine Blutabnahme, deswegen nehme ich gleich Blut ab
bei Ihnen
und ich schicke Sie auch zum Grundgern
Danach machen wir zusammen eine Ultraschalluntersuchung
Okay
gegebenenfalls je nach Befunde können wir auch eine Zitie veranlassen
Zitie, Bauch-Zitie veranlassen, okay?
Okay, gut, bin ich wieder einverstanden
Okay, dann können wir mit dem körperlichen Untersuchung anfangen, ja?
Ja, gut
Sie schreiben jetzt Ihre Sachen zusammen, fünf Minuten
Okay, und wann geht es weiter?
Noch etwas, unsere Kollegen fragen
Also meine Frage wäre jetzt als Patientin
Kann ich jetzt noch etwas trinken oder eventuell etwas essen?
Nein, Frau Schneider, Sie dürfen gerade nicht essen oder trinken, ja?
Aber wir machen, Sie bekommen von uns einen Zugang
Dann geben wir Ihnen ein Nahrungsalz, als Infusion
Okay
Ich habe ein paar Fragen gestellt, ich möchte ein paar Fragen stellen
Nur differenzial Diagnos
Haben Sie begleitet Symptome, Übelkeit andere Beschwerden, zum Beispiel Herzrasen,
Sodbrennen aufstossen, wie gibt es, oder nicht?
Nein, nein, ich habe das Gefühl, ich bin mir übel und ich habe diesen Druckschmerz
und etwas Schüttelfrost, aber so brennen und so habe ich nicht
Und Ihre letzte Stuhlgang, wann haben Sie?
Das war gestern, aber ich habe ja auch dann nichts mehr gegessen
Wie sieht aus, Ihre Stuhlgang?
Ich glaube, der war normal, da habe ich jetzt nicht genau geguckt, aber der war nicht auffällig,
der war nicht dünn, der war auch nicht verstopft, ich glaube der war normal
Gut, dann in fünf Minuten, bis gleich
Guten Tag Frau Oberarzt, wenn Sie Zeit haben, ich möchte Ihnen eine neue Patientin vorstellen
Frau Schneider ist 53 Jahre Patientin und sie ist 67 kg und 166 cm groß
Sie klagt über seit zwei Tagen berückende Abdominalschmerzen in rechtem hypochondrial Bereich
Die Schmerzen strahlen in die Schulter aus
Die Schmerzintensität liegt 7, 8 von 10 auf eine Schmalzkala, aber also hat 7 von 10
Und aktuell 5 von 10
Die Schmerzintensität hat vorher 7 von 8, 7 oder 8 von 10, aktuell 5 von 10 gelegen
Nein, also sie hat angefangen mit der Schmerz zwischen 5 und 6
Jetzt ist es zwischen 7 und 8
Genau, Entschuldigung
Die Wärmeumschlag verschlechtert die Schmerzten
Und als weiterer Beschwerden nennt er Übelkeit und Fieber 38,5 Grad
Und er hat ähnliche Beschwerden vor 3 Tagen auch gehabt
Sie hat vor 3 Tagen auch ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt
Vor 3 Wochen
3 bis 4 Wochen
3 Wochen waren diese Beschwerden ähnlich, aber nicht so stark
Genau, und als Auslöser beschreibt sie vor der Beschwerden
Also sie hat 10 Kuchen gegessen, dann sind die Beschwerden aufgetreten
Ja, also nach Sahnekuchen, Sahnetorte, eventuell ist das die Ursache, vermutet es
Ja, okay
Also in der Vorerkrankungen liegt Hypothrose seit 25 Jahren
Und Asthmabronchiale, also heute allergische Renitis vor
Ja, saisonales
Ja, Asthmabronchiale, ja, bei Polynosis, ne, vor euch noch
Ja, okay
In der Familienanamnese gibt es arterielle Hepatonee
Und bei der Vater, arterielle Hepatonee, bei der Mutter Diabetes und Scholledokos Lityasis
Ja
Kinekologische Anamnese, jetzt unabhängig und bei der Schwester auch gibt es Galliumblasen
Also Schollesystem ist auch bekannt
Ja, also Familienanamnese Eltern und Schwester und erst dann wieder
Okay, nochmal, ich darf dich nochmal wiederholen
Also es gibt keine positive Familienanamnese bezüglich Schollelitiasis
Ja
Sowohl die Mutter als auch die Schwester
Schwester
Okay
Gibt es Voroperationen bei der Patientin?
Ja, Voroperationen, sie wurde Ponsylectomy und Appendectomy
Und die Vegetative an Amnese gibt es Nectury, Nectury einmal nachts
Und ja, das war es
Ja, das war es
Ja, sie nimmt regelmäßig Altroxin, 50 mg morgens ein
Und bei Bedarf halbitumol spray
Okay, gut
Also von der Zusammenfassung habe ich verstanden, Herr Kollege
Patientin hat seit gestern akute Bauchbeschwerden
Bis VHS 7 bis 8
Ähnliche Beschwerden hatte sie schon einmal vor 3 Wochen
Genau
Und die Patientin vermutet, dass die Beschwerden jetzt akut auftraten
Eventuell nach dem Genuss von Sahnetorte
Sahnetorte
Okay, gut
An was denken Sie diagnostisch?
Nach den bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von Scholesistitis
Scholesistitis aus
Ja
Differenzialdiagnostisch
Kommt zum Beispiel an Ulcus ventriculi
Oder Pancreatitis
Oder
Ja
Ich denke, das sind schon die beiden wichtigen Differenzialdiagnosen
Ich denke, das sollte man erst mal abklären und abwägen
Im Rahmen der Basisdiagnostik
Was haben Sie für eine Basisdiagnostik vorzuschlagen?
Erst mal, ich würde natürlich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen
Danach brauchen wir eine Blutabnahme
Beim Blutabnahme möchte ich die Entzündungparamete großes Blutbild überprüfen, ob alles in Ordnung ist
Und natürlich möchte ich auch Leberwerte und Scholesistaseparameter kontrollieren
Pancreatis
Und die Patientin bleibt nicht dann?
Ja, die Patientin soll nicht stehen bleiben
Weil, wenn der Patient unser Verdacht richtig ist, können wir direkt einen OP durchführen
Oder erst mal, wir können ein Antibioterapie geben, danach vielleicht ja
Aber erst mal müssen wir erst mal die Untersuchungen bequemen
Und als Bildgebendes Verfahren, was schlagen Sie davor?
Können wir erst mal eine Röntgen-Untersuchung machen, aber Ultrasonografie
Bauch-Ultrasonografie ist auch sehr wichtig
Als erstes vielleicht eine Oberbauchsonografie-Bortschlagen
Dann kann man vielleicht schon eine Beurteilung von Leber- und Gallenblase sehen
Eventuell auch Pancreatis, man muss schon nicht die Luft die Patientin haben
Aber das wäre vielleicht der erste Schritt in der Bildgebung
Und dann können wir immer noch sagen Nativröntgen oder CT
Also so wie Sie das schildern, denke ich auch eher an eine Scholesistitis
Und ob man die gleich sofort akut operieren muss, ist ja immer diskutiert
Manche versuchen ja erst mal konservativ zu behandeln und dann intervall zu operieren
Das muss man schauen, aber offenkundig ist das ja nicht der erste Schub
Sondern vor drei Wochen war ja wahrscheinlich schon mal so eine zumindest leichtere Form
Wie die Patientin das schildert und bei dieser positiven Familienanamnese
Schwester, Gallensteine, Mutter, Gallensteine, muss man schon in der Richtung natürlich denken, dass da was zu erwarten ist
Gut, ja, ich bin so sehr zufrieden, wie Sie das gemacht haben
Sie waren jetzt bei der Schilderung, bei der Vorstellung vor dem Oberarzt etwas aufgeregt hat
Bei der Anamneseerhebung waren Sie sehr souverän und haben die Fragen sehr ruhig gestellt
Gut war, dass Sie umgeschaltet haben auf medizinische Fachbegriffe
Also von der Mandelentfernung zur Tonsilektomie, von der Blinddammentfernung zur Appendektomie, das wird ja gewünscht
Und das ist Ihnen denke ich gut gelungen
Und ich habe da ein gutes Gefühl auch für eine demnächst anstehende Prüfung
Auch bei Ihnen würde ich immer vorschlagen, machen Sie eher einfache Sätze, nicht zu lang, zu komplizierte Sätze
Dann weiß man nachher nicht, habe ich vorne schon ein Verb benutzt oder kein Verb
Zum Beispiel zu sagen, Frau Juhr-Schneider ist 53 Jahre alt und kommt mit akuten Oberbauchbeschwerden zu uns
Dann hat man schon mal gesehen, dass es eine Frau, das alter und was sie für Beschwerden hat
Dann können Sie vielleicht sagen, Frau Schneider ist 1,66 groß und 67 kilo schwer
Das sind dann einfache Sätze, die aber informativ auch sind
Und Sie haben keine Gefahr, dass Sie sich vergaloppieren, die Zukunft mehr machen
Das wäre vielleicht ein Vorschlag für eine Prüfungssituation
Haben Sie schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Ja, nächste Woche, Mittwoch
Und wo ist die Prüfung?
In Mainz
Ja, der Stadt Mainz geht es ja gut durch Biontech
Ich habe dich gewissen, wir haben ein hohes Aufkommen an Steuern bekommen durch Biontech
Ist Ihnen zu gönnen, die Firma hat ja auch eine wirklich tolle Entwicklung und tolle Produkte
Inzwischen auch an den Stadt gebracht, das müssen wir schon sagen
Gut, dann wünsche ich Ihnen für die Prüfung alles Gute
Vielen Dank, danke schön
Dann würde ich sagen, wir können gerne nächste Woche Mittwoch wieder